THEY SHOULDN'T EXPECT TO BE BACK
IN POWER ANYTIME SOON.
JOINING ME AS STEVE SCALISE,
AUTHOR OF THE GREAT NEW BOOK
"BACK IN THE GAME."
TOM HOMAN, FORMER ACTING
DIRECTOR OF I.C.E. ANNA FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR.
CONGRESSMAN, THE HOUSE G.O.P.
ONLY HAS 12 DAYS LEFT.
WAS I TOO HARSH ON MY ANGLE?
>> I THINK YOU LAID OUT THE
LANDSCAPE REALLY WELL AND
CLEARLY THIS GOES BACK TO
BARACK OBAMA'S PRESIDENCY WHEN
HE CREATED THE DACA PROBLEM
WITHOUT EVER TRYING TO SOLVE IT.
HE SAID LITERALLY COME TO
AMERICA ILLEGALLY, BRING YOUR
KIDS HERE ILLEGALLY.
HE NEVER TRY TO FIX IT.
WHEN PELOSI HAD THE HOUSE, SUPER
MAJORITY IN THE SENATE, THEY
NEVER TRIED TO BRING A BILL TO
FIX THE PROBLEM.
THEY WANTED A POLITICAL ISSUE.
AS YOU POINTED OUT,
PRESIDENT TRUMP COMES INTO
OFFICE, CHUCK SCHUMER INITIALLY
WAS WILLING TO WORK WITH HIM ON
A SOLUTION TO DACA THAT INCLUDED
FUNDING FOR THE WALL.
THEN THE RADICAL LEFT WENT NUTS
AND SCHUMER PULLED THE DEAL OFF
THE TABLE.
WE HAVE TRIED TO PASS BILLS
THROUGH THE HOUSE TO SOLVE THE
INTERIOR LOOPHOLE PROBLEMS THAT
YOU CITED SO MANY TIMES, AS WELL
AS FUNDING THE WALL.
NOT ONE DEMOCRAT.
WE'VE HAD TWO DIFFERENT
APPROACHES ON THIS, SO NO MATTER
WHERE YOU ARE ON THIS, THERE WAS
A CHANCE FOR YOU TO VOTE TO
SOLVE A PROBLEM.
NOT ONE DEMOCRAT VOTED.
>> Laura: COULD HAVE SHUT DOWN
THE GOVERNMENT.
>> THE NEXT TWO WEEKS, THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY'S BUDGET EXPIRES.
THIS IS ONE MORE BATTLE WERE
GOING TO HAVE AND IT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN IN THE NEXT FEW WEEKS.
>> Laura: JONI ERNST WAS ON
ONE OF THE OTHER SHOWS LAST
NIGHT OR YESTERDAY.
I WATCHED IT LAST NIGHT.
REPUBLICAN SENATOR FROM IOWA WAS
BASICALLY SAYING WE CAN'T SHUT
DOWN THIS GOVERNMENT FOR THE
WALL.
THESE ARE THE REPUBLICANS THAT
WE ARE DEALING WITH HERE.
STEVE SCALISE HAS DONE YEOMAN'S
WORK WITH EVERYTHING HE'S BEEN
THROUGH TO TRY TO STAND FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THEY ARE NOT MANY WHO WILL.
YOU HAVE SEEN THIS.
YOU AND I SAT HERE AT THIS
TABLE, TOM, AND YOU SAID TO ME
WATCH WHAT HAPPENS.
IT'S GOING TO GET WORSE AND
WORSE AND WORSE THAN RIGHT NOW
WE HAVE 5,000 PEOPLE A WEEK
CROSSING THE BORDER ILLEGALLY
SEPARATE FROM THE CARAVAN.
>> I HAVE BEEN AT THIS GAME FOR
34 YEARS AND UNFORTUNATELY
EVERYTHING ARTHUR IS COMING TRUE
AND I TELL YOU HAD SOME GREAT
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMEN TAKE
PEOPLE BY THE HORNS.
IT WAS A GREAT BELL.
SOME OF THE REPUBLICAN STUDENT
SUPPORTED.
NO DEMOCRATS DID.
IT FIXED THE PROBLEMS AND FIXED
THE LOOPHOLES AND GIVE SOME
RELIEF.
PERFECT BILL.
I SAID IT MANY TIMES.
I DON'T CARE IF YOU'RE
REPUBLICAN OR DEMOCRAT, THERE IS
NO DOWNSIDE ON SECURING THE
BORDER, NONE.
>> Laura: PAUL RYAN IS ON HIS
WAY OUT.
I LIKE HIM PERSONALLY BUT HE'S
NEVER WANTED TO FUND THIS WALL.
I'M GOING TO SAY.
PAUL RYAN IS NEVER WANTED TO
FUND THIS WALL.
HE DIDN'T WANT TO DEAL WITH THIS
PROBLEM FOR A WHOLE BUNCH OF
REASONS.
HE WAS NEVER COMFORTABLE WITH
THE PRESIDENT'S IMMIGRATION
AGENDA.
I THINK THAT LOOKING BACK, THAT
ENDED UP REALLY HURTING THE
REPUBLICANS.
IF YOU DON'T HAVE SOMEONE AT THE
HELM WHO IS CHAMPING WHAT THE
PRESIDENT IS DOING, AND I DON'T
THINK McCONNELL REALLY WANTS
TO DO IT EITHER.
HE TALKS A GOOD GAME BUT I DON'T
THINK EITHER OF THEM REALLY
WANTED TO DO IT.
>> WE WERE ABLE TO GET A BILLION
AND A HALF DOLLARS FOR FUNDING
FOR BORDER WALL IN THE BUDGET.
WE WANT MORE.
THE PRESIDENT HAS ASKED FOR
$5 BILLION.
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE US GET
THERE.
WE HAVE HAD A NUMBER OF BILLS OR
TRY TO SOLVE THAT PROBLEM.
LET ME MAKE THIS POINT ABOUT THE
END OF THE YEAR FUNDING FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY.
WHEN PEOPLE TALK ABOUT A
GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN, THEY TRY TO
USE IT IN.
ORDERED TERM TO TRY TO SCARE
PEOPLE.
OVER 70% OF THE UNITED STATES
GOVERNMENT IS FULLY FUNDED UNTIL
THE END OF NEXT YEAR.
INCLUDING THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEFENSE WHICH IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT.
IN THE PAST, YOU SAW OBAMA USED
THE TROOPS AS HOSTAGES TO TRY TO
SAY HEY, THE TROOPS WON'T GET
PAID UNLESS YOU GIVE ME X, Y, Z.
WE HAVE FULLY FUNDED THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE, INCLUDING
A PAY RAISE TO TROOPS.
THAT GOES THROUGH SEPTEMBER 30
OF NEXT YEAR.
ALL WE ARE TALKING ABOUT IS AN
IMPORTANT PART OF GOVERNMENT BUT
IT'S LESS THAN 30%, INCLUDING
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY.
THAT'S WHERE THE WALL FUNDING
COMES IN.
THERE WILL BE NO WIDESPREAD
GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN.
IT'S ABOUT FUNDING THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY
AND BUILDING THE WALL.
>> IN ADDITION TO THE WALL
FUNDING, I.C.E. NEEDS FUNDING.
IF I SEE CAN'T DETAIN PEOPLE
ARRESTED AT THE BORDER ENDED HIS
CATCH AND RELEASE AGAIN, MORE
CARAVANS GOING TO COME.
THERE'S NO CONSEQUENCE.
WHY WOULD THEY STOP?
>> Laura: RODNEY SCOTT, I KNOW
YOU KNOW HIM.
I HAVE INTERVIEWED HIM SO MANY
TIMES INCLUDING AT THE BORDER AT
SAN DIEGO.
HE SAID WHAT WE ARE SAYING,
CONTRARY TO WHAT THE BLEEDING
HEART MEDIA TYPES, MOST OF WHOM
WILL NOT SPONSOR ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS IF THEY HAD TO
PERSONALLY GUARANTEE THEIR
ECONOMIC INDEPENDENCE, THEY
WOULD NEVER DO IT, BUT THEY TALK
A GOOD EMOTIONAL GAME AND YOU
SEE THE PICTURES, THE SAD
PICTURE OF THE PEOPLE PLAYING.
RODNEY SCOTT KNOWS THIS SECTOR
BETTER THAN ANYONE, SAID THIS.
>> WHAT I SAW ON THE BORDER
YESTERDAY WAS NOT PEOPLE WALKING
UP TO BORDER PATROL AGENTS
MASKING TO CLAIM ASYLUM.
THEY WERE CHANTING, WAVING A
HONDURAN FLAG AND THROWING ROCKS
AT THE AGENTS.
IF THEY WERE TRULY
ASYLUM-SEEKERS, THEY WOULD HAVE
JUST WALKED UP WITH THEIR HANDS
UP AND SURRENDERED, AND THAT DID
NOT TAKE PLACE.
>> I KNOW RODNEY SCOTT.
HE'S A GREAT AMERICAN PATRIOT.
THE BORDER PATROL SENT THE TEAR
GAS OUT.
THEY DIDN'T SEND IT ON WOMEN AND
CHILDREN.
THE WIND DRIFT AND THAT HAPPENS.
HOWEVER, NBC DID A GREAT STORY.
THEY INTERVIEWED THAT WOMAN WITH
TWO CHILDREN IN THE PICTURE AND
SHE CAME OUT AND SAID SHE WAS
COMING TO THE COUNTRY TO JOIN
HER HUSBAND WAS ILLEGAL IN THE
COUNTRY IN LOUISIANA.
NOTHING ABOUT FEAR AND
PERSECUTION.
I HOPE THAT AS EXHIBIT A IN HER
FUTURE POLITICAL ASYLUM CASE.
EXACTLY WHAT I SAID.
PEOPLE ARE COMING FOR JOBS ARE
COMING HERE TO REJOIN.
>> Laura: IT'S A BIG LIE.
TRYING TO ILLUSTRATE THAT WE
ACTUALLY NEED REAL REPORTERS WHO
PUT ASIDE, WHETHER THEY DON'T
LIKE DRUM, LIKE TRUMP, THEY SAY
THIS IS HOW WE GOT HERE.
REAL PERSECUTION IS HAPPENING
ALL OVER THE WORLD.
CONGRESSMAN, YOU KNOW WHAT'S
HAPPENING TO PEOPLE LIKE OSSEO
BD, A WOMAN IN PAKISTAN.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS CLEAR
SAYING THAT THERE IS A LEGAL WAY
TO COME TO AMERICA TO SEEK
ASYLUM AND THERE IS NO LEGAL
WAY.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO LET YOU
STORMY BORDER AND CLIMB A FENCE.
GO TO A PORT OF ENTRY AND STATE
YOUR CASE.
MAKE YOUR CLAIM.
>> Laura: MEXICO IS GOING TO
HELP US, I THINK.
>> EVEN THE TIJUANA MAYOR SAID
THEY ARE GETTING A OVERRIDDEN
WITH SOME OF THESE PEOPLE THAT
ARE COMING TO ATTACK
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS.
NOT TO SEEK ASYLUM.
MOST OF THEM PASSED AT LEAST ONE
OF THE COUNTRY ALREADY.
>> Laura: HOW MANY LOST OR
THEY VIOLATE BEFORE THEY GET TO
SAN YSIDRO ON AVERAGE?
>> SEVERAL, SEVERAL.
THEY ENTER THE COUNTRY LEGALLY.
FIRST CRIME IS A MISDEMEANOR.
A LOT OF THESE PEOPLE BASED ON
OUR INTELLIGENCE HAVE BEEN
DEPORTED BEFORE SO WHEN THEY
ENTER THE COUNTRY ILLEGALLY, BUT
ONE THING I WANT TO SAY ON THE
TEARGAS.
FOR THOSE NAYSAYERS, PUT ON A
UNIFORM, STRAP A GUN TO YOUR
HEAD UP AND GET ROCKS THROWN AT
YOU AND TELL ME THERE WASN'T A
BETTER RESPONSE.
>> WHERE WERE THEY WHEN THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION WAS USING
TEARGAS?
>> Laura: BACK IN 2013, HOW DO
YOU DISPERSE A CROWD?
BUT RIHANNA CALLS IT TERRORISM.
SHE'S UPSET.
SHE DOESN'T HAVE SECURITY AT HER